[Music]
we all have bad ideas I know you for
example clicked on this video how's it
going everyone my name is Peter Pan and
today we're looking at don't fund me of
people that have bad ideas and then
decided I need money for this bad idea I
mean am I gonna put my own investment
into this yeah I don't really feel like
doing that I just believe in the idea
too much to put my own money in it so
let's see what people ask for money for
here we have a GoFundMe page for
I would like $3 for some green beans and
he got five well done
see gamers it's that easy you want some
green beans you can count on the
Internet to be there for you Wow should
I pay for racing my own children no I
don't really feel like doing that I
think the internet should do that
because as you all know raising a big
family is expensive you can help we all
know it's expensive so therefore you
should pay me what it is the push
thought version of logic my body
oh my body builder has been injecting
oil to make them bigger but now wants to
raise money to make them smaller begging
for UK surgery to reduce biceps I think
there's a good you look just like a B in
lessons so that's how she did it huh
that's how she got those games it all
makes sense now
I didn't say anything it looks natural
of course what am I talking about but
you know it's not just poor people
asking for money everyone needs a bit of
extra money like this televangelists
called Jesse Duplantis that needs 54
million why you may ask
he wants to fly a private jet why you
may ask his demons flying commercial Oh
Dimas fly commercial Oh God
I believe that if the Lord Jesus Christ
was physically on the earth today he
wouldn't be riding a donkey he suggested
you make a good point here is your 54
million sir you have changed my mind
here's your 54 have people oh my god
I guess rich or poor people like
self-awareness that's how it is
oh nothing like getting your kids
involved to get a boob job help please
have our mom get boobs she looks like
our dad Jesus Christ if all my Facebook
friends Stone is just 2 dollars guys
just 2 dollars if all of you watching if
all my subscribers just donates 2
dollars then I'll have 2 million dollars
and you know what I'll be generous I'll
give you $1 that's a hundred million
dollars seem like deal I think we have a
deal check out my only fans account
thank you so insane the legend that
started it all he was before our time
you know the money went to good use at
least I am raising money because I want
air pods because I deserve them because
I go to really hard school because my
parents made me anyways I am really good
person and I really like music
I am the epitome of a normal child give
me air pods what goes through people's
Briggs I don't understand this is the
problem with our generation I don't care
if I sound like a boomer but everyone's
a goddamn entitle and you know what I
want money from rich people because they
provide me services and innovations but
they're rich so I don't like it it's my
money now me I've seen a lot of these
pop up where it's they try to be funny
as an attempt to haha this is so crazy
we should give money through this right
Shrek flavored deodorant oh my god that
is so funny yeah I'll give them $43
spaghetti sauce oh my god oh my god no
[ __ ] way this is not real let's get
Kylie Jenner to a billion she has nine
hundred million no
oh how much did this get cuz I see that
bar go up and I don't like that
7,000 I sure wonder where that money
went
oh he went to charity okay fair enough
definition of self made right there I
need money for alcohol alright
how much you need five bucks twenty five
thousand twenty okay sorry I don't have
that on me my bad
I feel terrible about this this is
really pissing me off man I am 21 send
me money it's my birthday
gave me money
my girlfriend was a Jeep for Christmas I
can't pay for it so in the internet
shall you both deserve each other
oh my god she got 800 pounds
I want my 90 quid back because my date
called me Fang something mildly bad
happened to me
money money now you know you don't care
about other people Simms Simms did this
you know goddamn well it seems that did
this my queen you are not fat at all
here's a $90 I squeezed in a little
extra 10 so you're saying for me to
start my own business if I don't have
the money I have to take out a loan as
an investment and do my own risk
management wait so you're telling me I
have to work for money I am in between
jobs
nice little Zen hurt Vinny there that
really seal the deal this guy spent it
on a Twitter ad can anyone spare me ten
thousand pounds god bless you if you can
paid to promote more people will see
this there's someone out there this is
makes me hate only fans even more
goddamn it please have a broke girl out
girl can not be broke look I'm pretty
right money please
now God I'm losing faith in humanity
with every post oh no someone's basic
needs can't be covered
what other basic needs I need to get my
nails done by basics necessities like
Chinese food cooking gas money to go on
adventures that few of my stupid life
stories that will mean so much to me I
will show you all pictures of the things
I buy with your money well that's the
deal I will get a photo in return like
some I understand are clearly just
children but seeing adults do this is my
god like okay you want a Minecraft your
one dream and goal in life to get
minecraft on a PC I respect that that's
a kid and I respect that give that man
give that child is minecraft I get it
but may playstation 5 fund it's not even
out yet we don't even know the price of
the playstation ok why do you need the
money it's just for a PlayStation 5
nothing important do you have like a job
or something no then get one oh thank
God thank God people who shut these
bears down dammit
upgrade my gaming setup why not it's
like they have a blue Yeti headphones
hey hey hey you have it all what the
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up so someone need
foot surgery and they asked will the
funds be raised for any drugs and the
person replies that's none of your
business sir where you give me money
that's none of your business where that
money goes to sir
eight people like that okay the amount
of 15 people I've seen that at once and
intend to switch Jesus Christ you can
live without a Nintendo switch stop
ahead oh by the way camera quality epic
it's not gonna get better than this so
don't even ask Aaron mother flipping
Carter son of one of the Backstreet Boys
once hundred thousand dollars to stay on
top what does that mean
nobody [ __ ] care
go [ __ ] yourself Aaron Carter helped me
get an iPhone I have an Android 7 and
it's terrible and iPhone would be so
much better maybe it would maybe doesn't
not my [ __ ] problem have you heard of
that have you heard of that problem
get a job goddamn it I'm getting so
worked up ah you want a family home well
so did Emiliano papal I don't give up I
give you a break let that boy go pay for
your own goddamn Tokyo Disneyland no one
needs to essential oils they are not
essential that we call non essential
oils buy your own goddamn car
buy your own goddamn handbags I can't
take this anymore our lives again oh
this girl says she will love me forever
she just wants a car what the [ __ ] are
you sitting in then hmm what is that a
spaceship I don't think so you ain't
getting nada okay
sames need to get your [ __ ] together you
don't to slap your face in the goddamn
face psych yourself in your goddamn face
stop this we cannot let you understand
you're encouraging this behavior it's
like a rewarding a puppy for something
on the carpet you don't do that stopping
your sense now goddamn it
they sense now it doesn't matter if it's
your birthday everyone has a goddamn
birthday
it doesn't make you special surgery for
my legs yeah I need that too I don't go
asking the internet for it because I
can't stand you hopes well that's a
hilarious pun I will give this man
$60,000 right now cuz that was a funny
haha why don't we raise money for the
egg cuz I was also so hilarious
goddamnit I hate this I'm angry
I'm suffering this right now screw you
subscribe and check out my members it
goes all the charity ok it goes all to
charity mother changing the world mother
alright see you tomorrow
[Music]
it's time to race what was once
forgotten what creatures far spells and
poop troops awaits hope tears coming to
Nintendo's wait and remember it has a
very big TV pre-order promotion I mean
they gave me a check book version 11
[Music]